yo bootleg cab show man we got a special
guest in here
estg Louisville in the building
welcome sir what's up with you
um I haven't seen anybody smoke what
you're smoking what are we smoking right
now what is this is this like a just a
Black and Mild yeah okay
is this like a it's just a more
flavorful cigarette
I don't even know if you would say
flavor for this a bigger cigarette is it
stronger than like regular like if you
smoked a Newport would it be was that
stronger it's like three Newports oh
I'll give it a shot I'll give it a shot
just move it ain't really
that's not bad it ain't supposed to
inhale look like it though yeah I didn't
really inhale it I thought you I wanted
to taste it you know pause pause super
pause super welcome to man all right yo
um I just saw your new video uh you've
been on a drop in hella records I mean
we've been waiting on a new album so I
know that that is what is coming you're
not dropping all this music for nothing
right album is done Friday Friday is
coming
are you like in the studio all the
[__] time or are you like yo this
week I'm just knocking out a bunch of
[__] and then I'm gonna go do shows I'm
gonna go get my bag what is your like
creative process like
uh oh I'm always getting money so always
getting money oh yeah I could see that
just record just when whenever you feel
I got my own studio so yeah can you
record yourself like are you good with
Pro Tools that's how I started when I
was on a house arrest I said I learned
how to when I first started rapping so I
learned how to record that's the most
important thing because then you're you
don't have to depend on nobody to record
some [__] but now again now you got your
engineer yeah
uh you have some serious jewelry what is
the newest piece between these two
pieces
uh
is this like serious serious uh
I just got this one the Lamborghini
when you get a piece like this right do
they charge you full price or do you get
a any sort of estg discount
I want a discounted jewelry I just
curious I would take the discounted
jewelry no hell man I feel like back in
like the early 2000s a lot of rappers
had the discounted jewelry
pretty um
dude I still got it now I would have to
ask Boosie
got a lot of boots remember the old
school busy still got that [__] you
still got this right man do you remember
Brian Pumper the porn star
no oh Brian Pumper had these Julie bro
he's the one who turned out Lawrence
Fishburne's daughter who Brian Lawrence
Fishburne Neo from The Matrix the bald
black guy uh do you want a red pill or
the blue pill
named Brian Pumper and he turned out
Lawrence Fishburne's daughter but he had
these giant jewels that they were
talking about the porn [__] get
off of him yeah and you know let's get
off and pause
um yo so I actually heard that you're a
a huge Joe Rogan podcast fan
is this true I'm kind of new to Joe
Rogan but you've you've been you've been
kind of getting hip to his university I
think he's funny I think he's sarcastic
he'd be letting people just they'd be
saying they sit over and he be
he act like he's like oh yeah but you
could tell I don't know he might not be
might be for real but I I think it's
funny because I think he'd be joking
with him and they'd be dead ass
seriously oh for sure yeah how did you
how'd you like get it I'm new to the
whole YouTube World figuring out this
that's like the new TV it is the new TV
and then you like kind of let YouTube
just feed you whatever Rhythm whatever
whatever it is yeah you can you sit
there and wake up if you go to sleep
wake up have you seen um Theo Von's
interview with YG
know but I don't know theovan is the
white dude who's like kind of got the
country accent
but he's [__] hilarious he's a
comedian why do the country accent it
sounds like he had YG on nyg was like
show them sexy red and he was like oh
yeah I like me some of that and YG's
like you ever had some black black
ghetto [__]
Obama was like what
yeah that's dope man yeah Rogan is is
great have you learned anything random
from The Joe Rogan podcast because I'll
be learning the most random information
bro
that you let people talk
and they'll make the money for you you
gotta give them somewhere to come and
talk um
what about your thoughts on are you hip
to what's happening with the alien stuff
right now
because they're saying
you know this guy went and testified to
Congress that pretty much all but
admitting that aliens are a real thing
did you see that
[__] them aliens [__] still gotta pay
their bills tomorrow if they're before
anything to happen you still gonna have
to do you think aliens are real though
pstg how much do that affect Joe but do
you think they're real
I don't give a damn if they realize are
they gonna what they gonna change what
they gonna they gonna get [__] out of
jail I don't know that's exactly so [__]
all that I just know Independence Day
with Will Smith you remember that movie
no
you don't you've never seen Independence
Day when do they come out [__] how old
are you you're a lot younger than me
yeah well no you're not that much
younger than me it came out in like 97.
I was three years old yeah it's a
classical
they come and they [__] they blow the
White House up [__] it gets real real
raw they were very uh aggressive they
had to pay taxes at the end of that year
probably this is true do you guys pay a
lot of taxes in Kentucky
because I feel like in the South there
are a lot less in your pockets like in
California they'd be in our [__]
Pockets taxes is a
national government Bank no but I'm
talking about state taxes because yeah
obviously you're going to pay federal
taxes on everything I think it's just
depends on where you live at it the
property values high in certain places
the minimum wage is high in Cali yeah so
it's like a trade-off like you pay more
taxes but yeah probably minimum wage
like 20 I think it's 20. yeah what is it
in in Kentucky I don't know but it ain't
nowhere
near 20. so if it so it just add up the
same how's uh what's the weather I've
never been to Kentucky I've driven
through Kentucky but I'm never like
really hung out right like summertime in
Kentucky is it humid is it hot like what
is the vibe during the because it's been
hot as [__] I'm from Phoenix
was 119 last week when I was there you
could like cook an egg on the street
what's it like in in Louisville
summertime
it's hot this is everywhere else we get
all four seasons all four seasons yeah I
love it
um did you grow up a Cardinals fan
because there's no obviously
professional team there's the Wildcats
then in Louisville you got the Cardinals
Donovan Mitchell yeah oh shout out none
of them no no [__] man
we was they ain't giving none of my
[__] no scholarships or nothing had
another money's getting nowhere were you
at uh at a scholarship in Indiana State
right and not a Louisville yeah did you
try to go to Louisville and they just
did you had to go home anymore keep
talking about your Athletic program I
got you I respect that
they hey well it is what it is we got to
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our folks at my bookie man
look my bookie NFL season is approaching
and you know what they just added that I
love is that early cash out let's say
you got a ticket and it's looking great
you can cash out early on that ticket
all right I love it all right plus of
course my bookies got the full casino
going down and if you sign up right now
using the promo code bootleg they will
give you that first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars all right so head
over to my bookie ASAP um look we're at
uh NFL coming there's baseball you can
gamble on right now and of course the
full service casino blackjack with the
real dealer uh roulette craps whatever
you're into slot machines you could do
it and cash out right on my bookie all
right all you got to do is sign up with
that new promo code bootleg when you
sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're going to get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview I saw
you were obviously uh for you like uh I
saw one of your interviews you said that
you were getting off papers in 2023
are you officially off papers yep how's
that feel
they still on my like I don't know they
just
the the lmpd showed dirty and Louisville
like they
like it's like when you've seen that
advice
like little police is different terrible
yeah like they
because it's like they you you have to
go and do the time you have to deal with
whatever you have to do you have to pay
your fine but then they kind of keep
like this invisible like these invisible
handcuffs on you through probation I
just always had a thing like with the
pro like I on I never had no no
I never well you know how I need to be
acting like people teach them a lot like
the police right like
I don't want to say his name I think he
got four he was involved in the Brianna
Taylor [__] though one of the police
officers when I was little though he
walked like a little group of us home at
gunpoint though one of the dudes who
were involved in the ground yeah oh my
grannies uh I won't say
Turtle Creek and she lives
yeah it was Turtle Creek or Ben Creek I
forgot what numbers got they right next
to each other but yeah so when you were
a kid you and your friends like got
walked home like the cop had y'all like
man they wanted to do something Brianna
Taylor [__] that [__] just like
I don't know it just I I had my so I had
my own you had your own experience yeah
yeah I mean I see how they are on an
everyday basis I've been dealing with
these [__] my whole life yeah
ain't no police ain't they ain't never
help me are they still like um making it
hard for you to do shows back home yes I
had a show booked at the Yum Center
they told
whoever it is the security or whatever
people the engine told to promote they
didn't want me in there
then
promoters like Iowa I'mma just have just
babied in and he was like no because
baby my child bring G out because he did
before like on surprise some surprises
so
yeah that's how they do uh you know
Mazzy right mozzie in Sacramento they
won't let him perform nowhere that's
gotta be that's that and I do ain't
don't don't nobody do as much for the
city as as we do like
nobody like I didn't donate more money I
didn't gave did giveaways back to school
giveaways turkey drives Christmas [__]
you know I'm saying all type of [__] and
they act like it ain't nothing like the
last time I did a shoe giveaway last
year we gave away like retro Jordans
like good jewelry right right not the
team a whole lot of [__] like like
probably like five six hundred per shoes
like all Jordans and the powers that we
don't give a [__] and there was crowded
out there in the news the news station
made it look like
like it was a problem like it was a lot
of like they instead of reporting on
somebody giving all of this stuff away
to yeah the city they they made it look
like it was Ruckus and the police had to
be called the controller system which
wasn't true the police just came because
that's what they do but it wasn't no
wasn't nothing going on out there you
know what I'm saying like
Jesus they just try to flip it and make
it something bad like
but a lot of it come from experience
certain people in the community too
because it ain't like
like I don't know a lot of Street [__]
that act like they so street but they
moms and [__] be police officers and you
know I'm saying Community Watch
[__] and then that turned into
you know I'm saying they tell one side
up and not the other side of it making
me look like a monster but you know what
I'm saying how do you feel like you need
a dry snitch to their moms and [__] fear
me uh tell them [__] that's going on and
then knowing that their moms yeah yeah
it's straight though I was gonna say do
you feel like when something like that
happens right like the news covers an
event that's supposed to be a positive
event for the community but they cover
it in a negative light is there anything
you can do to help control that
narrative
[__] I'm the one giving the [__] what
what more can you well like I feel like
you know like like when you go online
and like clear it up like hey today was
like a good day like
no because it don't be matter you feel
me don't be mad I'm more of digestion I
don't care how how you receive it I know
like it's coming from you yeah you know
I ain't even attend the actual concrete
action though you feel me doing what I'm
doing like that's how it matters I feel
like intentions
that's true that's true who all uh who
do you have on this uh project that's
coming out Friday uh Gotti
um baby the
worst like a goddy bear
who that's what I'm missing
while uh we just had Rallo here last
week oh and yeah static me no static
mage of course it's Kentucky Legend rest
in peace
how do you
get the vocals
static at one million songs I've heard
I've heard he has like a like a crazy
hard drive of unreleased stuff that
people like hard drives drives yeah
so do you go through his family like you
go through like how do you get the
static major
that's crazy
it's it's crazy too because we don't
really like uh
yeah he's one of the more prolific
songwriters you know
and like I feel like his influence is
like never really like
acknowledged like it should be I won't
say they just opened up a static major
exhibit in Louisville wow
already
I think they trying to work on it up is
he on is it a verse or is it hook from
him
um
I'm gonna play if we don't want to say
so but it's he's all over the song Oh
that's fire that's dope hey we gotta
stop the
stop and tell you about our folks at Odd
Socks baby shout out to Odd Socks man
the most comfortable socks in the world
Listen they got all the licenses if you
love chips you know what I'm saying they
got the Funyuns they got the goddamn
Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet but they also
just introduce their draws that's right
we got odd talks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsocksofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're uh dealing
with erectile dysfunction or maybe your
thing ain't thinking like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you're asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking me your girl will be thinking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview when you get that
like like tell me the process do they
like let you come and like you you're
playing with my people it ain't no I'm
saying but like like let's say it's your
people right are you able to kind of
like go through a few joints on the
drive and be like I like this one or
like this one or they send it to you
like hey this one you can have this one
does that make sense
[Music]
just
she's musically inclined right A lot of
people hit up or stuff Drake you know
what I'm saying was it on on the
original beat that it was cut on or did
you take the vocals and put on a newbie
she got to be together with her people
and then you know she asked me
what I changed if I was like I just
wanted to let her do her thing so I'm
saying static
re-emerge he never left but just kind of
get more introduced to her I'm saying it
is kind of crazy because like if we
think about like Louisville and Kentucky
overall like
you guys are like a run right now you
know
I mean
Bryson yourself Jack Harlow
I feel like you guys didn't really have
too much of like a real national
identity but I feel like you in
particular have really like represented
like a side of Louisville that like we
never really got to see through a guy
like Bryson because he's obviously a r b
singer so you know for you like how
important is that for you to still kind
of like
make sure you're
kind of carrying the state make sure
you're representing the state nationally
make sure you represent the city you
know what I'm saying I don't feel no
pressure it's just
me I got
I know a lot of people used to like to
break it up with Bryce and Dragons but
at this point I feel like we gotta stop
breaking it up because if we're going
off sales and accolades and stuff like
I'm like the guy yeah you know what I'm
saying and um got no gimmicks or no
funny [__] with me I just dropped the
music yeah my life and I got
stats to prove and I know
[__] are getting the barber shop about
who's better I got gold Plex Platinum
Flex that's a lead artist you know what
I'm saying that's a big deal we got a
gold album the entire album it's a big
deal man so I ain't
oh no I don't feel like it's it they
shouldn't jumble it up and say this type
of music this type like artists I feel
like I'm the
leading the Forefront of you know saying
rap in general not just Louisville I was
gonna say what market for you started to
pick up on estg first outside of
Louisville like what was like that City
you were like oh this is spreading this
is moving somewhere like I could
actually go get a bag in this place like
was there a city that you remember that
like really kind of like
it was all at the same time kind of like
it just kind of all kind of happened
like wildfire quick I just was moving
around anyway so
people knew me like the streets knew me
anyway yeah they come with the music and
we pop up 80 [__] 80 chains 80 watches
it don't matter what if you're getting a
burning humming you know what I'm saying
yeah they're gonna they won't see what
you talking about yo um I've seen this
picture of you at the NFL combine yeah
which what you ain't seen no picture no
NFL well I saw you in like the NFL
combine looking like workout yeah like a
workout was that just a workout you were
doing for a team I don't know how you
see the picture you ain't read the
article that came with it I just saw a
YouTube video where they were talking
about uh you and like I was just
watching some of your high school
highlights and your college [__] like I
saw like what YouTube video you seen
dude I don't know man it was like a it
was like a YouTube video a show like you
announcing that you're going to Indiana
State and of course a YouTube video call
I don't know I just literally typed in
estg football highlights
and I was like damn this dude was a
beast
you play linebacker right
what do I got to do with
music and [__] right man no I'm just
curious because I'm a big football fan
so like I'm just like
I just I'm a huge football fan I find it
fascinating that like you really like
have like a real high level like
football run you know what I'm saying
before the rap [__] like took off so
yeah I just think it's fast but
obviously a part of your story so
I know it doesn't have anything to do
with what's going on right now but
that's fair
um I was gonna ask you like when it
comes to I remember when you signed with
Gotti I remember the the viral moment
where there was just all this cash and
at that time I felt like there was like
a bidding war going on for estg at that
moment
um one what made you rock with Gotti and
what is something over the last two or
three years that you have learned I mean
well
for the very first time in bootlegate
podcast history
we had someone walk off of the set
interesting
oh well there's the estg interview that
he was two hours late for
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Hardin in Las Vegas
the number one dispensary in the world
all right and we are so proud to be
partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine